[Musique]
o o le myosotis et puis la rose
ce sont les fleurs et qui disent quelque
chose mais pour aimer les coquelicots et
les mixages faut être idiot ça peut-être
raison oui mais voilà
quand je ferai des
tu comprendras
[Musique]
la première fois
je les fais elle dormait
à moscou
[Musique]
dans la lumière tall était au beau
milieu d'un champ de blé
et sous le corps de sage blanc
à laon batasuna
le soleil gentiment
comme annecy coquelicot
[Musique]
cocorico
c'est très curieux comme tes yeux
brillent entre rappelant la jolie fille
il varie si fort que c'est un peu trop
pour expliquer les coquelicots peut-être
raison seulement voilà en gelée prise
dans mes bras elle m'a donné
sans vos sriw et puis après
florian deal dans la lumière de l'été
on s'est tu aimais
et je tente appuyé
[Musique]
sur son coeur à la place du baiser
m'hamdi coquelicot
[Musique]
comme un petit peu coûteux
ça n'est rien d'autre qu'une aventure
la petite histoire et où je te jure
qu'elle ne mérite pas un sanglot née
cette passion des coquelicots attend la
fin vu qu'on prendra
1 entre les mêmes
qu'elle n'aimait pas et le lendemain
non je les ai revus
elle dormait à mon incident
dans la lumière tollé au beau milieu du
chanvre
mais sur le corps sage blanc juste à la
place ducale
il y a
trois gouttes de sang qui faisait comme
une folle
[Musique]
l'école publique au
surtout
et puis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]